I've never been hi I'm nervous I don't
know yeah I've always heard that edibles
are just on put you on a whole nother
type of high what are we making today
I'm making cannot fit which is phyllo
dough with ricotta and mozzarella and I
have mascarpone and I mix that up
right here you're gonna see me fuse with
the water-soluble THC so you see how it
measures out by the no leader so we're
gonna go down just one drop basically
yeah absolutely
do you smell any cannabis in there I
don't damn right well you started
cooking what we was it just because you
like to get high and you like the cook
so I was so sick of having the brownies
and the Rice Krispies there's no other
alternative use brownie or rice krispies
from every drug dealer ever and they all
tasted like so what I did was start to
put it into like puddings and cakes and
stuff like that and then it grew into a
more savory application how do you know
what to infuse well I infuse it based on
what I can control because it all comes
down to proper dosage because if you get
people too messed up it does not fare
well for really anybody involved now you
are about to do something Ruby we're
opening up the first cannabis infused
restaurant in the world yeah I know I
know
first world yeah is that me there's a
lot of things hurdles that we have to
jump it's gonna be done and it it should
be done by people that know what they're
doing I don't
if you've ever been to high off inedible
I know you said that you've never tried
it but beautifully haha
for those of you that have sometimes it
can be extremely overwhelming so we only
put it in certain ingredients so that we
can control it if you didn't want
cannabis we can just take that
ingredient out and replace it with a non
infused item that way people can enjoy
the experience on their own how did you
come up with your name I didn't want it
to be like ganja chef or weed chef right
so the herbal chef was kind of natural
and it also is THC that venom which is
our beloved tetrahydrocannabinol I'm
just looking my god so good all right so
what do you say to the people who have
never tried an edible before we do it in
such a way that it gets you lightly
elevated so that you're never
overwhelmed you don't want to just dive
in right away right you want to dip your
toe in you want to take your time don't
they just ease in yeah you can have a
long loving relationship with cannabis
but you got to take it slow Chris that's
so good hmm that's worth it
[Music]
you